Les paradoxes des jumeaux et du grand-père
Dans l’épisode 5, on a vu que les horloges
en mouvement tournent moins vite.
Donc si vous abandonnez votre jumeau sur Terre
et si vous faites le tour de l’univers,
alors votre jumeau sur Terre va voir votre
horloge tourner moins vite.
Et donc, alors que 50 ans défilent pour votre
jumeau sur Terre, il est possible que moins
d’un an s’écoule pour vous.
Du coup, quand vous reviendrez sur Terre,
vous serez plus jeune que votre jumeau.
Tout va bien ? Hein ? Vous êtes sûr ?
Off 1.
Voyons maintenant ce qui se passe si l’on
raisonne dans votre référentiel.
Dans votre référentiel, c’est votre jumeau
qui est en mouvement, et c’est donc son
horloge qui tourne moins vite.
Du coup, avec la même raisonnement que précédemment,
on devrait conclure cette fois que vous serez
plus vieux que votre jumeau.
Hummm…
Qu’est-ce qui se passe ? A-t-on une contradiction
fondamentale au coeur de la théorie de la
relativité ?
Off 2.
La réponse de base pour résoudre ce paradoxe
consiste à faire la remarque que pour revenir
sur Terre, vous avez dû faire demi-tour à
un certain point.
Du coup, vous n’êtes pas resté dans un
référentiel inertiel, et la relativité
restreinte ne s’applique donc pas à votre
référentiel.
Le deuxième raisonnement que l’on a fait
est donc faux.
Sauf que.
Sauf qu’en relativité générale, il est
tout à fait possible que votre vaisseau fasse
le tour complet de la galaxie et revienne
sur Terre, et ce, sans n’avoir jamais accélérer.
Off 3.
En voici un exemple tout bête.
Décollez à très grande vitesse, et coupez
les moteurs.
Vous suivrez une orbite autour de la galaxie
autre que celle que suit la Terre.
Et de façon cruciale, le long de cette trajectoire,
vous ne subirez aucune force.
Même pas la force de gravité.
Car la gravité n’est pas une force.
Mais du coup, quand vous reviendrez sur Terre,
serez-vous plus jeune… ou plus vieux…
que votre jumeau ?
Off 4.
La réponse réside dans la métrique de l’espace-temps.
Comme je l’ai dit dans une vidéo précédente,
le temps passe, et on est donc constamment
en mouvement à travers l’espace-temps.
On suit nos trajectoires à travers l’espace-temps.
Le rythme auquel passe le temps dépend alors
justement de cette trajectoire.
Il se trouve que les trajectoires en ligne
droite sont des maximiseurs locaux du temps
qui se passe entre deux points de l’espace-temps.
Et le sens de ce que je viens de dire est
un petit peu délicat.
Off 5.
Ce que ça veut dire, c’est que si on prend
une ligne droite à travers l’espace-temps,
et si on perturbe légèrement cette ligne
droite, alors le temps va passer moins vite
le long de la trajectoire modifiée.
Autrement dit, si votre jumeau suit la ligne
droite et si vous suivez la ligne modifiée,
alors, au bout du chemin, vous serez plus
jeune que votre jumeau.
En un certain sens, en ne suivant pas la ligne
droite, vous avez fait de plus grands pas
à travers l’espace-temps à chaque unité
de temps.
Et du coup, vous arriverez au bout du chemin
en moins de temps.
Sauf que contrairement à ce qui se passe
dans une course, vous n’aurez pas à attendre
votre jumeau…
Oui, car je vous rappelle que ce qui est dessiné
ici est l’espace-temps.
Pas l’espace.
Quid maintenant de deux lignes droites distinctes,
qui se coupent à deux reprises dans un espace-temps
courbe ?
Off 6.
Là, c’est dépend de la courbure en différents
points de l’espace-temps.
Et c’est là qu’il faut faire de longs
calculs très compliqués.
Mais pour faire simple, en gros, on peut dire
que les trajectoires qui traversent des régions
très courbées de l’espace-temps font de
plus longs pas à travers l’espace-temps
à chaque pas de temps.
En particulier, si votre trajectoire se rapproche
très près d’un trou noir, alors c’est
bien vous qui serez plus jeune que votre jumeau.
Comme dans le film Interstellar, vous pouvez
finir plus vieux que des personnes qui étaient
plus vieilles que vous dans le passé.
Et si vous pensez que ça c’est bizarre…
vous n’avez encore rien vu…
Off 7.
En 1949, le mathématicien Kurt Gödel, que
l’on considère souvent comme le plus grand
logicien de tous les temps, surprit Einstein
pour son anniversaire, avec un cadeau assez
peu ordinaire…
Il offrit à Einstein une nouvelle solution
cosmologique incroyablement mystérieuse aux
équations de la relativité générale.
L’univers de Gödel était si courbé que
des trajectoires de ligne droite de l’univers
pouvaient être amenées à boucler sur elles-mêmes.
Autrement dit, les équations d’Einstein
autorisaient le…
wait for it.
Voyage dans le temps ! Si l’univers est
tel que Gödel l’avait imaginé, alors il
est possible de suivre une trajectoire en
ligne droite à travers des régions très
courbées de l’espace-temps, et que cette
trajectoire nous ramène dans notre passé.
C’est…
super bizarre !
Si bizarre qu’Einstein rejeta la validité
physique de l’univers de Gödel, même s’il
en reconnaissait la validité mathématique.
Ça vous rappelle quelque chose qu’Einstein
a fini par regretter ?
Mais là pour le coup, j’ai du mal à aller
à l’encontre du rejet d’Einstein.
Et vous pouvez imaginer pourquoi.
L’univers de Gödel n’interdit pas le
paradoxe du grand-père…
Off 8.
Si vous pouviez revenir dans le passé, vous
risqueriez de tuer par accident votre grand-père.
Mais si votre grand-père meurt avant d’avoir
donné naissance à votre père, alors votre
père ne pourra pas vous donner naissance,
et vous ne seriez pas né.
Pire, vous ne seriez pas retourné dans le
passé, et vous n’auriez pas tué votre
grand-père.
Qui aurait donc donné naissance à votre
père, lequel vous aurait donné naissance.
Donc vous seriez né.
Off 8.
Mais vous seriez donc retourné dans le passé
et vous auriez tué votre grand-père.
Qui n’aurait pas donné naissance à votre
père, lequel ne vous aurait pas donné naissance.
Et vous ne seriez pas né.
vous ne seriez pas retourné dans le passé,
et vous n’auriez pas tué votre grand-père.
Qui aurait donc donné naissance à votre
père, lequel vous aurait donné naissance.
Donc vous seriez né.
Ça n’a aucun sens…
Vous ne pouvez pas à la fois être né et
ne pas être né.
Et c’est pourquoi la plupart des physiciens
d’aujourd’hui rejettent la possibilité
du voyage dans le temps…
même si un logicien pur comme Kurt Gödel
ne pourrait pas se permettre de rejeter une
telle possibilité.
Ah !!! Gödel ! Et je peux vous dire que la
relativité générale n’est pas le seul
domaine qu’il a complètement bouleversé…
Des décennies plus tôt, il avait déjà
prouvé que la consistence des mathématiques
ne pouvait pas être prouvée…
Mais ça, c’est pour
une autre fois…